We are on the way to Shikoku once more for a 2-day seminar with Chiba Sensei.
This is of course a Daito-ryu seminar
This is our last video for this series.
But we'll probably do some more later on.
We are about 10 people coming from Tokyo
And there are 30 or so people coming from Osaka.
We are meeting them in Osaka and they will drive us down.
Daito-ryu is like the etymology of Aikido, like the Latin of the Greek of Aikido.
Most of the Aiki principles of Aikido have disappeared so that is why we are going to Daito-ryu to find them.
This is a very interesting research.
Imitating Aiki is easy, anybody can do it.
But to really find the principles by oneself is almost impossible.
One has to go back to the source to find that.
This is why we go back there regularly and seek these principles.
The weather is great today so we are travelling by Shinkansen.
All the conditions are there for a great seminar.
Guillaume has a new camera so he is very happy to play with this new toy.
We are full of energy and spirit.
I hope that you liked the video because we put all our heart in it.
Hopefully it will give you a lot of information.
You are welcome to Japan at any time if you want to experience Daito-ryu.
You are welcome, we can take you there.
Thank you for your interest, best regards and see you soon!
Every teacher is a truth in himself.
The real question is "How competent was that teacher's own Sensei".
Everything stems from that.
That is what this scroll represents right? A lineage, a common source?
The irony is that it also implies a notion of one being just a puppet.
To become the best, one has to become like a branch.
We seek our original trunk in order to become a stronger branch.
Therefore, you can say that you stem from that particular trunk.
The only true question is whether you are a thin or a thick branch.
The more the branches grow, the better, because then, the nore the trunk growths with them, and as the trunk grows, so do the branches.
For me, it is the same problematic.
Why am I here before you?
It is for the opposite reason.
I arrived from the bottom,
and wondered which of the Sensei I knew was going in the right direction.
Three of these teachers seemed to go in one particular direction and by following them inwards, I got to Chiba Sensei.
What Chiba Sensei shows me now is the opposite view, the one that branches outwards.
One has to think about how one can transmit knowledge and become a guide.
That is the meaning of the word "Sensei".
There are some teachers who do not know how to make the right guidance choice.
When I let them do as they want, I can clearly that.
Although what they do works for them, it won't work as well for someone else.
If we pay attention to this, we can correct the defects but it requires a lot of good sense.
There resides the individuality of each of us.
As a student, when you start thinking things like: "In spite of my efforts, it doesn't work",
a few words with the Sensei can get you unstuck.
Just say: "Sensei, I did as you said but it doesn't work, here look..."
This is what you should say.
You must become Human Beings!
That is the meaning of Deshi, this importance of...
There is a famous Japanese say that goes:
"Whatever happens, the first Sensei that one adopts will remain one's Sensei".
It means that if you follow a Sensei for a while, it will be very difficult to change, so you'd better not get it wrong.
The Sensei should not reprimand the student, he should pay attention.
Else, the student will think: "He gets mad at me but I can't do it".
What is this reprimand about then?
The Sensei should say: "Look, this is not the right way to do it, you should do it like this instead".
It is easier that way, because he teaches as a fair man.
this is the way that one brings knowledge.
Of course, there are people who don't get it because they just "can't".
This is at that point that the incompetent warrior starts doing impossible things. It can't be helped.
Even I, if I was doing something impossible, I would get stuck.
This is what happens when you make things up.
And on the other hand, there are true geniuses.
The best thing to do is to bring the way of the movements to the best of our ability.
This is the true question.
One must grabs his chance and attempt to become a good branch.
The one who comes without this question, with or without an opinion, has to be taught this.
This is the role of the teacher.
If this takes place, it creates a connection between Human Beings [Ningendoshi].
"Ningen" is written like she "space" between people [or People within their own "space"].
This is what links them, there is a space between them.
If this space wasn't there, it would create conflicts.
There we get the link between the "puppet" and the "human being".
Yes.
This space, "Ma" represents the pedestal on which the human being is constructed.
One must open this space, otherwise it gets distended.
If the human being disconnects itself, he becomes part of the "mass" of people.
All of this is pretty well put.
Yes, the Kanji characters...
Today is Sunday
It is the day of the seminar with Chiba Sensei.
He came in wearing street clothes
and he is going to teach the whole seminar like that.
The reason is that he is ill
and that his wife did not want him to go teach, so she refused to give him his keikogi.
Chiba Sensei replied that he would do it anyway!
So since he will do the whole course in street clothes, he decided to show informal techniques,
some sort of applications.
It is a pretty funny to do
even though we are a bit lost because these are rather unusual, mostly secret techniques.
Go to the other side
so only his feet can move.
If you want to kick, it is easier from this side.
It is there right?
This is the kick of Gyaku-Ude-Dori
The kick goes like this.
So if the blow comes like this,
You have to do like this
Or it can become something like this.
It means that we have to take the shortest path, the quickest way.
Remember that!
This is how you do a chest grab,
like this,
or like that.
Take the lapel with your index like this.
That's how you grab.
Then you can do that!
On the throat!
This is how you grab in reality, take good note of this.
So what do you do against that?
When you are held like that, the side that you chose to dodge is crucial.
You think you can dodge but that does not prevent my movement.
Go that way, yes, stretch my arm.
But I can still come closer.
So you have to come towards me.
You have to go that way and this other hand has to act as a guard.
After that, Kote-gaeshi, you grab with this one.
What are you doing?
You have to grab from here, it's quicker.
The other one if for protection.
Now try to turn your hips.
This is where you have to do it.
Oh well, it is still a bit early to show you that isn't it?
I'll explain that to you.
Which side would do?
The body goes forward so it is dangerous, my own fist can come back at me.
It is the same in boxing, you go forward.
Same in Daito-ryu.
Do you understand?
So for Kotegaeshi, it is "Kote ga rachi" [twist/screw the forearm]
Why do you hold like this?
You have to take the thumb, and then hold firmly.
You enter like this right?
You have to grab this way.
How do you disarm?
You take it this way.
Do you understand?
That's it!
Before meeting Chiba Sensei, I had practiced the fixed "Kata" form with other Sensei.
When I saw Chiba Sensei, I thought that what he was doing was very different.
Part of it was Kata but the techniques had more life.
In Aikido, we talk about "Nagare" when the techniques are performed with flow.
Therefore, I wondered whether "Nagare" was the ultimate form of Daito-ryu practice?
It is a question of individuality, some people are more or less "agitated".
When the partner comes...
No, what you must understand is that we used to train in very tight spaces.
You have to think about this.
It is very difficult to unbalance the partner when one can't move much.
This is "Aiki".
If the partner comes back, one must retake "Ma"; one's distance [Ma-ai]
This is really important.
In this situation, when the attacker comes, he only has to take one step, one step and a half max, to be able to grab.
It is within that space that he is going to develop his attack and that it is the easiest to "enter".
Therefore, you have to wait for him.
Which guard are you going to take?
If one has to say it, the way that you adopt a guard will affect the way he will come, this is human isn't it?
See, if you take a left guard, he will come from the left.
He won't come from the front.
This is an essential [Gokui], secret [Hiden] point of doing it.
There is no guard.
The natural position [Shizentai] will come and you will be able to counter.
Nowadays, there seems to be an interest on the part of foreigners who come to Japan we have to cater for that need while continuing working.
This is why I think that research only is not sufficient.
We saw it clearly during our latest Takumakai gathering.
Regarding the propagation of Daito-ryu in future, do you have particular hopes or plans?
This is...
Sorry, it is a strange question...
A hope? It is a question of body, just like we said before.
My hope is that we can unite via training,
and that Daito-ryu becomes a medium for encounters, fusion through the heart.
This is how we could make it last.
I teach 2 seminars per year and people come to absorb through their eyes the techniques of Shikoku
which, once they are integrated, can help grow solid branches to that trunk and help the whole tree to grow.
This is what I want.
But first, we have to get out of the current mediocrity,
because right now, much of these people think a bit too highly of themselves.
Words are part of the folklore, they are just a sort of makeup.
Yes, my question was not very good, what i meant was: "What is your hope, not necessarily as a Sensei, but as the Human Being Chiba Tsugutaka?"
Until now, Shikoku's Daito-ryu was a bit obscure, which allowed it to keep its specificities,
but if it opens up, there is a risk that it loses itself.
So what is your personal opinion about opening Daito-ryu to foreigners and spreading it abroad?
For example, you and Guillaume practice with so much dedication and enthusiasm,
that I hope you can manage to promote our approach in France or elsewhere,
to show the techniques to people and help them understand beyond the few pictures that they have seen.
It is always better to practice amongst human Beings.
Because we need both to integrate ourselves and reach out to others.
I think that we covered pretty much everything right?
Yes Sensei, thank you very much!
Perhaps I have not been clear enough on some things?
It is going to take us some time to sort all of that out, perhaps a month.
I don't mind if it takes time.